il ya quelques années j'ai découvert à
la bibliothèque nationale de france
un livre intitulé l'art en place ce que
bon leur et blanc excuse de bourbon
publié en allemagne en 1848 le livre et
son auteur
gustav holst la monarchy était
totalement inconnu à la réunion en
métropole en allemagne au fil des amis
les recherches menées aux archives ont
fait découvrir un franco allemand qui a
été à bourbon entre 1842 et 1845
rédacteur en chef de la feuille
hebdomadaire professeur d'histoire et de
philosophie au collège royal secrétaire
au conseil coloniale et fondateur de
l'institut coloniale pour l'instruction
de la population défavorisée dans le
cadre de ses fonctions elle n'a marqué
s'est investi dans les mesures
préventives à l'émancipation des
esclaves